[Applauso]
vi chiedo di immaginare quello che ho da
dirvi vi chiede in particolare di
visualizzare ciò che vi dirò e nel farlo
parlerò al singolare ognuno di voi e
quindi chiude pure gli occhi rilassati
fa il respiro profondo se serve in
realtà serve a me però così faccio
credere sia per voi e si pronto pronto a
visualizzare bene tutto quello che
vedremo allora sei nella cucina di casa
tua
nella cucina di casa tua in particolare
davanti al frigorifero sei davanti al
frigo lo aprì e ci trovi un enorme
idrante dentro al suo frigo c'è un
idrante quello rosso che usano i
pompieri e questi durante ti colpisce
con un getto d'acqua allora tu
barcollando si muove verso il tavolo e
trovi il tavolo ricoperto di birilli si
è trasformato in una pista da bowling
pieno di berilli allora doppiamente
sconvolto sconvolta vai verso il
lavandino per sciacquarti il viso con
acqua fresca e riprenderti allora sei
davanti al lavandino lo aprì e dalla
mandino esce una folata di bora una
folata di bora che ti congela il viso
non farti domande per il momento anzi
fatele perché esce della bora dal mio
lavandino a questo punto è bisogno di
calore per sciogliere questo ghiaccio
allora vai verso i fornelli e fai per
accenderli ma non si accendono allora
prendi un bel sacco di carbone e lo
rovesci sui fornelli tentando di
accendere il fuoco con il carbone ma non
funziona allora ti rassegni sul micro
onde di ci metto qualcosa nel microonde
riscaldo quel qualcosa che lo userò per
sciogliere il ghiaccio quindi vai verso
il microonde tanto le cose non possono
andare peggio di così apri il microonde
e le cose vanno peggio di così infatti
c'è esattamente uno zoo in miniatura
dentro al suo microonde un piccolo zoo
dentro al microonde ci sono delle
giraffe delle scimmie un elefantino ok
un momento ti chiedi ma è solo la cucina
a trovarsi in queste condizioni o magari
anche il resto della casa allora fai
un'ispezione fare un'ispezione partendo
dalla camera da letto vai verso la
camera da letto e per prima cosa
controlli l'armadio quindi aprile
armadio
è tutto regolare dentro l'armadio si è
tutto regolare c'è semplicemente un suv
attaccato ad un enorme bombola di
ossigeno dalla quale respira è più che
il suv noti proprio la bombola perché
più grande del sud stesso chiodi
l'armadio è ok e arrivato il momento di
farsi un riposino quindi vai verso il
letto
prendi la coperta pronto per stirare la
sua e distenderti ma questa rimane
incollata rimane incollata a letto
perché qualcuno ha cosparso lo spazio
tra la coperta è letto di dentifricio
dentifricio che ha fatto effetto colla
quindi tu non ti puoi si stende sul
letto perché pieno di dentifricio allora
vai verso la scrivania e dice mi siede
davanti alla scrivania
faccio qualche respiro profondo e
capisco cosa sta succedendo
quindi ti siedi ma non appena ti siedi
la scrivania comincia a levitare si alzò
e cominciò a volare via allora tu alzi
lo sguardo e noti un'enorme massa di
palloncini attaccata alla scrivania
palloncini all'elio che quindi la
sollevano un po come nel film up ma al
posto della casa dei protagonisti c'è la
tua scrivania ok il nostro viaggio si
interrompe qui potete aprire gli occhi
viaggio apparentemente senza senso lo
vedo anche dalle vostre facce quindi
grazie della fiducia innanzitutto ma
ripercorriamo quello che è successo ok
siamo partiti dalla cucina eravate in
cucina avete aperto il frigo e cosa
c'era dentro al frigo un
esattamente un idrante poi siamo andati
verso il tavolo barcollando il tavolo
era ricoperto di birilli allora abbiamo
scelto di sciacquarsi il viso abbiamo
aperto il lavandino ma dal lavandino è
uscita una folata di
esattamente poi fornelli non
funzionavano sacco di carbone sui
fornelli ma anche questo non ha
funzionato allora andiamo verso il
microonde
apriamo il microonde queste belle cosa
c'era dentro al microonde uno zoo uno
zoo in miniatura a questo punto
ispezione verso la camera da letto
apro l'armadio e c'è la bombola di
ossigeno del nostro amico sub poi perché
non mi sono potuto stendere sul letto
perché era ricoperto di
esattamente di dentifricio e infine la
nostra scrivania è volata via a causa
dei palloncini all'elio
ecco questa non è una storia senza senso
questa è la tavola periodica voi avete
appena memorizzato inconsapevolmente
sopra senza sforzo il primo elemento di
ognuno degli otto gruppi principali
della tavola periodica non lo sapete ma
è così adesso ripercorriamo la storia
questa volta dandole un senso ok siamo
partiti in cucina abbiamo aperto il
frigo per prima cosa c'era un idrante
idranti idrogeno primo elemento nel
primo gruppo in alto a sinistra e l'arca
ma noi non interessano i simboli poi
sono andati verso il tavolo dove c'erano
i birilli birilli berillio primo evento
del secondo gruppo poi saltiamo i
metalli di transizione andiamo nella
parte destra
apriamo il lavandino esce la folata di
bora bora terzo gruppo poi sui fornelli
dove esce il sacco di carbone carbonio
nel microonde c'era uno zoo azoto n
infine per gli ultimi tre gruppi
andiamo in camera da letto
apriamo l'armadio c'è la bombola di
ossigeno ossigeno il dentifricio del
letto rappresenta il cloro primo
elemento del vii gruppo la effe e infine
i palloncini all'elio rappresentano
lelio primo elemento dell'ottavo gruppo
ecco se avessi avuto qualche minuto in
più di aver fatto memorizzare l'inter a
tavola periodica nello stesso modo
purtroppo sul palco del the da un
massimo di 18 minuti quindi non possa
effettivamente farvi memorizzare l'inter
a tavola periodica perché ho altre cose
da raccontarvi però voglio darvi la
dimostrazione che sia così quindi adesso
andremo a completare il primo gruppo
quindi chiudete nuovamente gli occhi
chiudi gli occhi rallenta un attimo
rilassati visualizza di nuovo tutto
molto bene se sempre davanti al frigo la
è aperto e c'è l'idrante ok che ti ha
colpito con un getto d'acqua ma prima
non hai notato che insieme all'acqua è
schizzata fuori una batteria al litio da
l'idrante una batteria al litio quella
dei cellulari e questa batteria ha
colpito una delle uova del tuo frigo in
particolare ha colpito un uovo sodo un
uovo sodo che si rompe sente rumore
claque immagina lo si rompe nasce fuori
una banana banana particolarmente grande
che ti incuriosisce ti avvicini ma ti
passa davanti un ladro che ruba questa
banana e poi lo stesso ladro tira fuori
dalla tasca un enorme paio di cesoie tu
ti spaventi e lavorati possa fare del
male ma in realtà il ladro con le cesoie
taglia semplicemente la bandiera della
francia
evidentemente gli rode ancora per la
questione della gioconda quindi da
l'idrante schizzata fuori la batteria
ali che ha colpito un uovo sodo crack
esce fuori la banana enorme un ladro ti
passa davanti alla ruba tira fuori delle
cesoie e taglia la bandiera della
francia
aprite gli occhi adesso conoscete a
memoria anche il primo gruppo della
tavola intero perché perché idrante
idrogeno e fino a qui ci siamo schizza
fuori la batteria al litio litro secondo
elemento che colpisce un uovo sodo sodio
terzo elemento enea dal quale esce fuori
una banana potassio che viene rubata
rubidio da un ladro che tira fuori delle
cesoie cesio con le quali taglia la
bandiera della francia francia di nuovo
senza sforzo solo immaginando con
qualche minuto in più avremmo completata
nello stesso modo perché perché dopo
avevamo il tavolo con i birilli berilli
vita i birilli potevano cadere in testa
a carlomagno magnesio che dava un calcio
a qualcuno calcio eccetera eccetera
eccetera ok quelle che abbiamo usato
sono delle tecniche di memoria in
particolare il palazzo della memoria e
il link method ecco la cosa interessante
che ci sono delle persone che portano
quest'abilità all'estremo andando ben
oltre il loro punto di origine che per
voi adesso che avete appena imparato
queste tecniche avete appena scoperto
questo mondo
quindi ci sono delle persone che portano
all'estremo quest'abilità cimentandosi
in competizioni di memoria gare
nazionali internazionali mondiali con
conseguenti regole mondiali
ecco voglio darvi un'idea di quello che
alcune di queste persone sono in grado
di fare facendo vedere alcuni record
mondiali di memoria ad esempio c'è una
disciplina che si chiama five minutes
numbers in cui concorrenti hanno cinque
minuti per memorizzare quante più cifre
possibili all'interno di questa pagina
questo muro di cifre fa quasi paura sono
480 cifre ecco immaginate secondo voi in
cinque minuti quante di queste cifre
sono state memorizzate fate una stima
nella vostra mente quante di queste
cifre all'interno di 480 ecco il record
mondiale attualmente ammonta a
630 pardo non viene ingannato perché
c'era anche una seconda pagina oltre ai
480 635 memorizzate in cinque minuti
questa è l'esatta foto fatta l'anno
scorso al record in germania
poi ci sono altre discipline per esempio
quelle delle carte c'è howard kurtz in
cui concorrenti devono memorizzare
quanti più mazzi di carte possibili
in un'ora il record mondiale attualmente
di 35 mazzi e nuove carte nelle carte
del 36esimo evidentemente non ha fatto
in tempo
ma attenzione non la prima carta di 35
mazzi l'ordine esatto di tutti i 52 le
carte di 35 maxipiù 9 un totale di 1829
carte memorizzate correttamente in
un'ora dalla prima all'ultima
chiaramente un serial killer poi c'è
un'altra disciplina speed cards in cui
concorrenti devono memorizzare questa
volta un singolo mazzo di carte 52 carte
da poker più velocemente possibile
il record europeo questa volta per fare
umili per non spaventarmi troppo ma mi
sa che è troppo tardi e di 15 secondi e
12 15 secondi per memorizzare un intero
mazzo attenzione difficile fisicamente
scorrerlo un mazzo di carte in cui di
secondi e scorre le vederle una dura
dice ho provato ci sono riuscito ma è
difficile perché devi anche essere
veloce con le dita ecco e visti questi
record la domanda che sorge spontanea è
ma perché perché cimentarsi in qualcosa
di così apparentemente inutile
ripetitivo fine a se stesso al di là del
come la cui risposta è più semplice
perché usano le stesse tecniche che
abbiamo visto prima che avete visto
funzionare su di voi e insieme a tanto
allenamento tanto talento il tutto messo
insieme porta a questo però tu memorizzi
35 mazzi non ora io arriva in 5 minuti
del rischio chi vince personalmente sono
molto più interessato all'aspetto
pratico di queste tecniche come abbiamo
visto prima con la tavola periodica come
può fare uno studente con le date di
storia gli articoli di codice i termini
anatomici i nomi delle persone un
discorso io in questo momento sto usando
il palazzo della memoria per ricordare
questo discorso consista esattamente in
ogni momento cosa devo dire non ha paura
di scordarmi lo posso anche rilassarmi
concentrarmi sulla gestualità e su tutto
il resto aspetto pratico utile non
ripetitivo e fine a se stesso senza
offesa per chi compie queste gesta
comunque preso dall esperimento da
record non mi sono presentato per cui
lasciate che mi presenti io sono andrea
muzzi e attualmente sono campione
mondiale di memoria di regole che avete
visto prima sono miei del fatto io
non potete dire che io vi abbia
ingannato perché non ho mai detto di non
esserlo
questo sono io in germania l'anno scorso
davanti al record mondiale di 630 cifre
questo sono io nel 2019 in cina davanti
al record mondiale di 35 mazzi c'è
scritto 1829 che sono le carte
memorizzate al pc ai campionati mondiali
in cina del 2019 che ho vinto sono stato
un mese fino adesso lasciatemi
riprendere una sono quello che sono e
infine questo sono io sempre l'anno
scorso in francia davanti al record del
mazzo di carte quello che rimane un
timer che stimi a 15 secondi e 12 ecco
quella di prima non era umiltà riguarda
il record europeo e che c'è un ragazzo
asiatico che ha fatto 12 secondi è 12
non ho ancora scoperto dove abita
e a questo punto potreste voi chiedere a
me ma perchè perchè fare qualcosa di
così apparentemente inutile ripetitivo
ecco in realtà io una risposta alla
domanda perché cielo ed è un'altra
domanda ovvero quanto oltre possiamo
spingerci con la nostra mente quanto
oltre possiamo andare rispetto al nostro
punto di origine in qualcosa di così
estremo specifico e nel provare a dare
una risposta a questa domanda voglio
iniziare facendo vedere il mio punto di
origine dove sono partito quando aveva
appena imparato la conversione fonetica
che è la tecnica che si usa per
ricordare i numeri l'avevo appena
imparate mi sono subito cimentato nella
memorizzazione di numeri e
fortunatamente ho anche documentato il
tutto su un quaderno scrivendo poi lo
ritrovate lo ha portato qui per voi
nelle slide quindi aveva appena imparato
questa tecnica in poco più di cinque
minuti quante cifre ho memorizzato
non memorizzate 24 su 26 lo vedete
evidenziato quella sopra la tecnica in
cinque minuti attenzione 24 su 26 sono
due numeri di telefono e mezzo per anche
due errori qualunque essere umano con la
memoria naturale ci può riuscire e non
avevo 56 anni ne avevo 17 poi li stato
relativamente tardi da adesso ne ho 22
21 o 22 ok peggior battuta che potessi
fare è fatta così almeno ce li togliamo
subito ok non me le fate voi poi ho
fatto un altro tentativo 40 cifre su 40
vai però sempre in 5 minuti e mezzo più
di quanto poi ci ho messo a fare 630 e
poi ho continuato
tra alti e bassi potete vedere qualche
faccina triste con tanti errori e
qualche punto esclamativo contento del
mio settimo giorno di pratica con 40
cifre su 40 in due minuti però a livelli
ancora bassi
ecco e guardandomi indietro
guardando questa strada percorsa dal
punto di origine ai record questo
miglioramento
trovo tutto questo estremamente
motivante quasi addictive che crea
dipendenza perché perché ogni volta io
pensavo di essere vicino al mio limite
ogni volta pensavo che il mio limite
fosse dietro l'angolo ma ogni volta mi
sbagliavo e l'ho superato e man mano che
miglioravo si spostava in avanti con il
mio miglioramento la mia idea di limite
che quindi non è mai stata reale è più
andavo avanti più strada facendo ne
avevo conferma e lo capivo e poi cosa
posso fare posso proiettare questo
miglioramento fatto quindi guardandomi
indietro in avanti perché se ogni volta
io pensavo di essere vicino al mio
limite ma ogni volta mi sbagliavo posso
chiedermi quanto ancora avanti può
andare tutto questo e quindi alla
domanda quanto oltre possiamo spingerci
con la nostra mente non c'è una risposta
non c'è una risposta precisa non ci può
essere
è questo il punto
io posso solo sapere dove il limite non
è spingendomi ogni volta oltre e questo
è ancora più motivante è una ricerca
infinita verso l'estremo infinita di cui
non si conosce la fine
io ho usato questo pretesto delle gare
di memoria per non restare fermo alla
mia origine andando poi a proiettare
questo miglioramento e quest'idea di
limiti in altri campi della mia vita
iniziando a chiedermi se ci fossero
altri campi altre situazioni nelle quali
mi ero auto imposto dei limiti che mi
hanno fatto imporre dei limiti del tutto
superabile ecco per concludere ci sono
tre punti dai concetti che vorrei
arrivassero al di là del fatto che
adesso sapete che potete letteralmente
ricordare qualsiasi cosa con le giuste
tecniche
il primo punto l'abbiamo appena vista
riguarda i limiti che sono quasi sempre
non reali autoimposti ma lo capiamo solo
strada facendo solo una volta che
abbiamo iniziato il secondo punto è
realtà è una domanda ed è quante cose ci
perdiamo quante cose non iniziamo solo
perché non pensiamo di esserne in grado
perché non sappiamo se ne valga la pena
perché non so se sono portato ecco io
ero quasi quasi in quella situazione
perché quando ho iniziato non avevo la
minima idea di poter raggiungere questi
risultati
volevo solo migliorare nello studio però
ho fatto un primo passo un piccolo primo
passo senza troppe aspettative
poi ha fatto un altro un altro ancora
come avete visto dalla foto ma avrei
potuto non farlo
frenato da chissà chi da chissà cosa
quindi la domanda che vi lascio è quante
cose ci perdiamo frenati dal nulla cosa
in cui potremmo potenzialmente arrivare
anche molto lontano per poi proiettare
questo miglioramento in altri campi
della mia vita iniziando della vita
iniziando a migliorare a 360 gradi
il terzo punto è che il miglioramento
sia specifico in un campo come in questo
caso sia più generale di nuovo e di noi
come persone è una macchina che si può
autoalimentare nel giusto mix di
guardare avanti e guardare indietro
proiettando in avanti miglioramenti
fatti e quelli non ancora fatti per cui
può essere una macchina che si
autoalimenta
ma deve prima essere messa in moto e
questo dovete farlo voi quindi di
qualunque cosa si tratti
grande o piccola anche se non avete idea
di dove vi possa portare fate il primo
passo fate quel piccolo primo passo
altrimenti non scoprirete mai quanto
lontano potete arrivare grazie
[Applauso]